[Music]
okay you notice men's backsides do you
notice women's behinds I I'm an ass Cal
I yeah I love I love a good but like
like Jesse Biel Jessica Biel has an
amazing but but like my my everyday my
daily but inspirations are at the gym
and oh and you go to the gym and you
look at women oh I'm all over them like
I'm like okay girl has see when I go to
the gym and look at women that way I get
asked to leave and I'm like you go girl
in there you know I am always I've been
thrown out of more women's gym you know
I am blessed to to work out at a gym
that that has a lot of adult
entertainment actresses a lot of porn
porn gals salt-of-the-earth really sweet
girls wait wait wait wait wait
how do you know that that's what they do
for a living I guess so you recognize
them I recognize like you're the ones
from you know whatever yes okay I've
seen your work I love it and let me get
some tips not on that but like cuz your
butt looks great um but I also compete
with them and they don't realize that
we're basically having like the Olympics
they're just not aware that we're in
competition with each other so if you're
looking at them like on a Stairmaster
yes and I'm on this next one like you're
not getting off before me I'm not gonna
lose you I'll tell you I can have a
porno but - yeah
I'm doing it going in so that's this is
the most erotic thing I've ever listened
to I'll follow them to like you know
they have like the gyms have like the
juice bar and I'll you know I watch and
see what they're ordering and I'm like
oh vegan let it sit with it yeah
they don't eat meat there you go kids
interesting that is interesting
so you see you're monitoring everything
that these these porn actresses are
doing and to emulate them to have a
similar figure I'm on the born bed
yeah born diet okay let's talk about I'm
not mind is just wiped clean now born
diet sounds like the terrible marketing
it's the porn diet get out but it
totally works